Summers just around the corner, so give your body the care it deserves with Osea's best-selling Andaria algae body oil. Created by infusing Andaria seaweed in barrels of botanical oils, it leaves skin silky, soft, and glowing. Plus, it's clinically proven to improve elasticity and deeply moisturize without feeling greasy. It's safe, clean, vegan skincare. Get 10% off your first order at OseaMalibu.com with code GLOW, plus free shipping on orders over $60. Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis center. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website.
夏日将至，是时候用欧舒丹畅销的安达利亚藻类身体精油来好好呵护你的肌肤了。这款精油将安达利亚海藻注入植物精油桶中萃取而成，能让肌肤如丝般柔滑、水润亮泽。此外，经临床证明，它能有效提高肌肤弹性并深层保湿，却绝不油腻。这是一款安全、纯净且纯素的护肤品。访问 OseaMalibu.com，在结账时输入优惠码 GLOW，首单即可享 9 折优惠，订单满 60 美元更可免运费。本期节目涉及严重且往往令人痛心的事件。如果您在任何时候觉得需要心理支持，请联系您当地的危机干预中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序上或我们网站上的本期节目简介。
Nestled within the historic DuPont Circle neighborhood in Washington D.C.'s old city, is Swan Street Northwest, an exclusive residential strip lined with Victorian-style row houses. With the White House only a mile north, Swan Street is a highly desirable location for wealthy city dwellers who seek leafier surroundings. One address, a four-bedroom, three-story abode with city views, is what's called a hotseller, the kind of house that doesn't stay on the market long. Since the incident in 2006, the intruder has not returned to the address, ensuring residents within can now sleep easy. In D.C. emergency number one, operator 6752, do you need police, fire, or ambulance?
坐落于华盛顿特区老城历史悠久的杜邦环岛社区内，是西北天鹅街，一条两旁林立着维多利亚式联排别墅的高档住宅区。白宫仅在北面一英里处，天鹅街对于寻求绿树成荫环境的富裕城市居民来说是一个极具吸引力的黄金地段。其中一个门牌号是一处拥有四间卧室、三层楼高且能欣赏城市景观的住宅，被称为抢手货，是那种在市场上停留不久的房子。自2006年的事件发生后，闯入者便再未回到这个地址，确保了住户们如今能够高枕无忧。这里是华盛顿特区紧急求助热线，6752号接线员，您需要警察、消防员还是救护车？
I'm D.C. community, remaining ambulance. What's wrong, ma'am? We had someone named us in our house, evidently, and they stabbed somebody. Okay, somebody's inside the house now? I don't know, we heard. Are they bleeding? You see someone bleeding? Someone is bleeding in our house. Okay, where's they bleeding from?
我是华盛顿特区居民，需要救护车。怎么了，女士？显然有人在我们的房子里袭击了我们，他们还刺伤了某个人。好的，现在有人在房子里面吗？我不知道，我们听到了。他们在流血吗？你看到有人在流血吗？我们家里有人在流血。好的，他哪里在流血？
I think in the stomach. In the stomach, is he conscious? Calm down for me, I'm going to send some help, okay? Female or male? It's a male, he's a friend of ours, you're spending the night with us. Okay, and who was the person that stabbed him, do you know? Is he conscious? We need names going through.
我想是在胃部。在胃部，他有意识吗？请为我冷静下来，我会派人过去，好吗？是女性还是男性？是个男的，他是我们的朋友，今晚在我们这过夜。好的，你知道是谁刺伤他的吗？他有意识吗？我们需要核对名字。
Ma'am, this is somebody. No, he's not conscious. He's not conscious at all? No, we need someone right now. Is he breathing? Listen to me, calm down, I'm going to help you, okay? Is he breathing? I'm upstairs, and he's downstairs.
女士，这是某个人。不，他没有意识。他完全没有意识吗？没有，我们需要马上有人过来。他在呼吸吗？听我说，冷静下来，我会帮你的，好吗？他在呼吸吗？我在楼上，他在楼下。
I don't know. Okay, who's downstairs with him? My partner is downstairs with him right now. He told me to go upstairs and call the police immediately. I just went upstairs and... Okay, who's the person? Okay, I'm sending parents and the police. Okay, who's the person that stabbed him?
我不知道。好的，谁和他一起在楼下？我的伴侣现在正和他一起在楼下。他叫我上楼立刻报警。我刚上楼然后……好的，那是谁？好的，我正在派医护人员和警察过去。好的，刺伤他的人是谁？
I don't know. We think it's somebody with an intruder in the house. We heard. It's time to go. Ma'am, calm down. It's one street north west, am I correct? Yes, it is. Is the person that stabbed him, is he still in the home?
我不知道。我们觉得是个闯入者在屋里。我们听到了。该走了。女士，冷静点。这里是西北天鹅街一号，我没记错吧？是的，没错。刺伤他的人，他还在屋里吗？
I don't know. The person had one of our knives. The person that stabbed him ran out the door with a knife? I think so. Okay, anybody get any type of description of the person that came in the home? I have no idea. We have no description. We heard the chime and we heard the screams from our friends.
我不知道。那个人拿了我们的一把刀。刺伤他的人拿着刀跑出门了吗？我想是的。好的，有没有人对进来的人有任何形式的描述？我完全不知道。我们没有描述。我们听到了风铃声，然后听到了朋友们的尖叫声。
Okay. And so we came running downstairs. We ran and... So you both was upstairs and your friend was downstairs? Yes. You heard the door open and then you heard the screams? We didn't... I didn't hear the door open until after the screams and then we ran down the stairs and we heard...
好的。所以我们跑下了楼。我们跑了……所以你们两个当时在楼上，而你们的朋友在楼下？是的。你们听到门开了，然后听到了尖叫声？我们没有……直到尖叫声之后我才听到门开的声音，然后我们跑下楼梯，我们听到……
We have an alarm and so the chime went off. Okay. Is the ambulance... We really need the ambulance. Okay, they're around there, ma'am. Go to the door. They should be putting up any moment, okay? I'm afraid to go down the stairs.
我们有警报器，所以风铃声响了。好的。救护车……我们真的需要救护车。好的，女士，他们就在附近。去门口。他们随时都会到，好吗？我不敢下楼梯。
The person who downstairs was the person that was assaulted? No, we're on the second floor. Okay, so somebody need to go to the door for the pyramid. You're not sure if that person's still in the home or not? I have no idea. Okay, we have pyramids around, okay? What time is it? What time is it at the moment?
楼下的那个人就是遇袭的那个人吗？不，我们在二楼。好的，所以得有人去门口接医护人员。你们不确定那个人是否还在屋里？我完全不知道。好的，医护人员就在周围，好吗？现在几点？现在几点了？
Yes. 2354, is it 1154, ma'am? Yes. I'll stand in line with you. I will stand in line until somebody gets here, okay? I won't hang up. We need them right now. I'm not hanging up.
是的。23点54分，是11点54分吗，女士？是的。我会一直陪着你。我会一直在电话里陪着直到有人赶到，好吗？我不会挂断电话。我们现在就需要他们。我不会挂断。
But we need help now. Okay, they're in row, ma'am. They are in row. Let me know when you hear the pyramid. Can you look out the window and see if you hear them coming? I'm looking out the window and I see nothing. I see nobody. Okay, same like for Apple, but they are in row, ma'am.
但我们现在就需要帮助。好的，女士，他们在路上了。他们正在路上。当你听到医护人员的声音时告诉我。你能看下窗外，看看能不能听到他们过来吗？我正看着窗外，什么也看不到。我看不到任何人。好的，跟苹果一样，但他们在路上，女士。
They're coming. I see them. Here they are. Here they are. They're there? You're going downstairs. Okay. I'll stand in line with you till you open the door for a pyramid, okay?
他们来了。我看到了。他们来了。他们在那吗？你正下楼去。好的。我会一直陪着你，直到你为医护人员开门，好吗？
Help us. We inform a staff on our second floor. What is this? Ma'am. I know it's really an emergency. I know he's maybe... He's hurrying. Ma'am, this won't be okay.
救救我们。我们在二楼通知了工作人员。这是什么？女士。我知道这真的是个紧急情况。我知道他可能……他在赶时间。女士，这不会没事的。
Ma'am, this won't be okay. Ma'am, this won't be okay. This won't be okay. This won't be okay. It was just before midnight on Tuesday, August 2, 2006, when the ambulance pulled up outside a grey brick row house on Swan Street, Northwest. A resident, Victor Zaborski, met the paramedics out front, still on the phone to 911. Panic and distress made his voice sound higher than usual,
女士，这不会没事的。女士，这不会没事的。这不会没事的。这不会没事的。2006年8月2日，星期二午夜前不久，一辆救护车停在了西北天鹅街一栋灰色砖砌联排别墅外。一名居民维克托·扎博尔斯基在门前迎接了医护人员，他手里还拿着拨打911的电话。恐慌和悲痛使他的听起来比平时更高亢，
leading the operator to mistake him for a woman. Between sobs, Victor informed the paramedics that someone had been stabbed on the second floor. They rushed past him into the house and ascended the steep wooden staircase just inside the front door. About halfway up, they spotted another male on the landing above, Dylan Ward. When the paramedics asked Dylan what was going on, he silently raised a hand and pointed down a short hallway. He was gesturing towards a nearby room. Following his direction, the two paramedics entered the small space. Against one wall was a sofa bed that had been unfolded and prepped with linen. A man sat perched on one side. He was Joseph Price, the third and final resident of the house.
导致接线员误以为他是一位女性。维克托在啜泣间隙告知医护人员，二楼有人被刺伤了。他们从他身旁冲进屋里，沿着正门内侧陡峭的木质楼梯往上走。走到大约一半时，他们在上方的平台看到了另一个男性迪伦·沃德。当医护人员问迪伦发生了什么事时，他默默地举起一只手，指向一条短走廊。他正朝着附近的一个房间示意。顺着他的方向，两名医护人员进入了这个小空间。靠墙放着一张已经展开并铺好床单的沙发床。一个男人坐在其中一侧。他是约瑟夫·普赖斯，这栋房子的第三位也是最后一位常住居民。
Next to him, lying face up on the sofa bed, was a fourth man. His pupils were fixed and dilated, skin pale and cold. Two weeks earlier, Robert Juan checked his inbox and noticed an email from an old friend, Joseph Price. Joseph was replying to a request Robert had recently sent him. Robert had only just landed a role as general counsel for Radio Free Asia, an accurate and uncensored news source for Asian countries with poor media practices. It was the perfect job for the 32-year-old. As a fourth generation Chinese-American, Robert was passionate about racial equality. On Tuesday, August 2, 2006,
在他旁边，仰面躺在沙发床上的是第四个男人。他的瞳孔固定且散大，皮肤苍白冰冷。两周前，罗伯特·万查看收件箱时，注意到了一封来自老朋友约瑟夫·普赖斯的电子邮件。约瑟夫是在回复罗伯特最近发给他的请求。罗伯特刚刚获得自由亚洲电台总法律顾问的职位，这是一个为媒体环境恶劣的亚洲国家提供准确且未受审查的新闻来源的机构。对于这位32岁的年轻人来说，这是完美的工作。作为第四代华裔美国人，罗伯特对种族平等充满热情。2006年8月2日，星期二，
Robert's workday was set to be longer than usual. He had to stay after hours to attend a legal education course, which wouldn't end until after 9pm. The late finish was an ideal, as Robert lived 20 miles from the Radio Free Asia office in Washington DC and would have to commute to work again early the next day. So, in the weeks leading up to the event, the extremely organized Robert contacted some DC-based friends to see if they could host him for the night, including Joseph Price. The pair had met 15 years earlier in college. Although they had repeatedly tried to catch up for dinner, it had been a while since they'd seen each other. Consequently,
罗伯特的工作日注定要比平时更长。他不得不加班参加一个法律教育课程，直到晚上9点多才结束。这么晚结束很不理想，因为罗伯特住在距离华盛顿特区自由亚洲电台办公室20英里远的地方，第二天一早还得通勤去上班。因此，在事件发生前的几周里，极其有条理的罗伯特联系了一些住在特区的朋友，看他们是否能留宿他一晚，其中包括约瑟夫·普赖斯。两人在15年前的大学里相识。尽管他们曾多次试图约饭叙旧，但他们已经有一段时间没见面了。因此，
Joseph emailed Robert back, saying he was happy for him to crash at his house on August 2. That morning, Robert stood on bustling Connecticut Avenue, where he kissed his wife Kathy Goodbye. It was 8.45pm, and the couple had caught the Metro train together into DC to go to their respective jobs. Later that night, Kathy received a call from Robert. He had just finished up at his course and was on his way to visit the night shift at Radio Free Asia. Afterwards, he would take a cab to Joseph Price's house, one and a half miles away. As they said their goodbyes, Kathy told her husband, Have a good night. I love you.
约瑟夫给罗伯特回了邮件，表示欢迎他在8月2日那天来他家借宿。那天早晨，罗伯特站在熙熙攘攘的康涅狄格大道上，吻别了他的妻子凯茜。当时是晚上8点45分，这对夫妇一起坐地铁去华盛顿特区各自的工作岗位。那天晚些时候，凯茜接到了罗伯特的电话。他刚刚结束课程，正准备去拜访自由亚洲电台的夜班人员。之后，他将搭乘出租车前往一英里半之外的约瑟夫·普赖斯家。在道别时，凯茜对丈夫说：“祝你今晚过得愉快。我爱你。”
As Joseph Price waited for his guest to arrive, his partner Victor Zaborski returned home from an interstate business trip. Joseph informed Victor that Robert won would be staying over, but Victor was too tired to wait up and greet the visitor. He decided to retire for the night and catch up with Robert in the morning. Victor went up to the main bedroom on the third floor, climbed into bed, and turned on the television to unwind. Robert arrived at around 10.30pm and was greeted by Joseph, as well as Dylan Ward. Dylan knew Robert too and was friends with him, but not to the extent of the others. The trio gathered around the kitchen table and made small talk over glasses of water.
正当约瑟夫·普赖斯等待他的客人到来时，他的伴侣维克托·扎博尔斯基结束了州际商务旅行回到家中。约瑟夫通知维克托说罗伯特·万要来留宿，但维克托太累了，等不及迎接这位来访者。他决定回房休息，第二天早上再和罗伯特叙旧。维克托上到三楼主卧室，爬上床，打开电视放松身心。罗伯特于晚上10点半左右到达，受到约瑟夫以及迪伦·沃德的迎接。迪伦也认识罗伯特并且是他的朋友，但关系不像其他人那么深。三人聚在餐桌旁，一边喝着水一边闲聊。
Like Robert, Joseph Price, Victor Zaborski, and Dylan Ward were all corporate professionals in their mid to late 30s. Joseph was a partner at an internationally renowned law firm and the director slash general counsel for a non-profit that supported the LGBT community. His partner, Victor, was the director of marketing for the Milk Processes Education Program, famous for their Got Milk advertising campaign. Dylan Ward held an associate of culinary arts degree and had also earned a master's in children's literature, which he used to write, edit, and publish children's books. He also worked alongside Joseph as development director for the LGBT non-profit.
和罗伯特一样，约瑟夫·普赖斯、维克托·扎博尔斯基和迪伦·沃德都是三十多岁到四十岁之间的公司专业人士。约瑟夫是一家国际知名律师事务所的合伙人，也是支持LGBT群体的非营利组织的董事兼总法律顾问。他的伴侣维克托是牛奶加工商教育项目的营销总监，该项目以其“喝牛奶了吗？”广告活动而闻名。迪伦·沃德拥有烹饪艺术副学士学位，还获得了儿童文学硕士学位，他用这些来写作、编辑和出版儿童读物。他还与约瑟夫一起担任LGBT非营利机构的发展总监。
The conversation at the kitchen table revolved around family, work, the hot weather, and house repairs. But the chat was short-lived. As 11pm drew near, Robert was tired and wanted to get a good night's sleep. He told Joseph they would catch up further over breakfast. Dylan and Joseph led Robert up to the second floor. After turning right at the top of the stairs, the trio headed down a short hallway, passing a bathroom and sitting area before reaching the home office. The room was toward the front of their house and had three long, narrow windows overlooking the street outside. Inside, a sofa bed had been prepared for Robert. His hosts also pointed out the bathroom down the hall so Robert could take a shower.
餐桌上的谈话围绕着家庭、工作、炎热的天气和房屋修缮展开。但闲聊很短暂。随着临近晚上11点，罗伯特感到疲倦，想要好好睡个觉。他告诉约瑟夫他们会在早餐时再进一步叙旧。迪伦和约瑟夫带着罗伯特来到二楼。在楼梯顶部右转后，三人顺着一条短走廊往前走，经过一间浴室和起步区，然后来到了家庭办公室。这个房间位于房子的前部，有三扇俯瞰外面街道的狭长窗户。里面，已经为罗伯特铺好了一张沙发床。他的主人还指了指走廊尽头的浴室，以便罗伯特可以洗个澡。
The three men then went their separate ways. Joseph continued upstairs to the third floor bedroom he shared with Victor. He switched off the television and went to sleep. Dylan took a sleeping pill and went to his own room on the same floor as the home office. As Dylan waited for the medication to take effect, he read a magazine. From his room he could hear the shower running. It stopped after a few minutes. Then he heard a click as the door to the home office closed. The sleeping pill taking effect, Dylan soon drifted off into a deep sleep.
这三个男人随后分头行动。约瑟夫继续上楼，回到他和维克托共用的三楼主卧室。他关掉电视去睡觉了。迪伦吃了一片安眠药，回到自己位于家庭办公室同一层的房间。当迪伦等待药物起效时，他看了一本杂志。从他的房间里，他能听到淋浴流水的声音。几分钟后声音停了。接着他听到咔哒一声，家庭办公室的门关上了。安眠药药效发作，迪伦很快沉入梦乡。
Earlier that night, Joseph had been downstairs when he noticed something out of place. A large windowed door in the kitchen led to a patio. This small, fenced-in area at the rear of the house had a table, chairs, and barbecue grill. Joseph's attention was drawn to something on one of the patio's exterior lights. He went outside to investigate, only to discover it was just a spider. Joseph headed back into the kitchen, closing the door behind him. He didn't realize, and no one bothered to check before bed, that the door's deadlock was in the vertical position. Joseph had forgotten to lock it.
那天早些时候，约瑟夫在楼下时注意到有些东西不对劲。厨房里有一扇带大窗户的门通往露台。这个位于房子后方的小型带栅栏区域设有桌椅和烧烤架。约瑟夫的注意力被露台上一盏室外灯上的某个东西吸引了。他走出去查看，结果发现那只是一只蜘蛛。约瑟夫回到厨房，随手关上了身后的门。他没有意识到，而且在睡前也没有人费心去检查，这扇门的插销正处于垂直位置。约瑟夫忘记把它锁上了。
Shortly before midnight, Joseph and Victor were awoken by the sound of their doorbell chime, alerting them that an exterior door had been opened. Going through either the front or rear doors of the house would activate this chime. Neither man thought much of it. They had a tenant who lived in the separate basement suite, and her comings and goings sometimes caused the chime to go off. But then, they heard a strange noise. It was a breathy, quiet sound, like a muffled grunt or scream. Dylan Ward heard the same noise, but he was drowsy from his sleeping pill, and this prevented him from fully acknowledging it. He fell back asleep.
午夜前不久，约瑟夫和维克托被门铃的报时声惊醒，这提示他们一扇外门被打开了。穿过房子的前门或后门都会触发这个报时声。两人都没把这当回事。他们有一个住在独立地下室套房的租客，她有时出入会引发这个提示音。但随后，他们听到了一种奇怪的声音。那是一种带着喘息的轻柔声音，就像被闷住的哼声或尖叫声。迪伦·沃德听到了同样的噪音，但他因为安眠药的药效而昏昏欲睡，这使他没能完全意识到这一点。他又睡着了。
Unlike Dylan, Joseph and Victor were unsettled. They decided to investigate the strange sound. Just as they got out of bed, they heard it again. This time, they were certain it was a low scream. They raced down to the second floor, and upon entering the home office, they saw Robert Wahn unresponsive on the fold-out sofa. Joseph rushed to check Robert's pulse, and realized blood was seeping from his chest. He yelled at Victor, who was screaming in panic, to call 911. Joseph then grabbed a towel and pressed it to Robert's wounds. The commotion woke Dylan, who left his room to find a frantic Victor on the phone,
与迪伦不同，约瑟夫和维克托感到不安。他们决定去查看这个奇怪的声音。就在他们起床时，他们又听到了这个声音。这一次，他们确信这是一声压抑的尖叫。他们冲到二楼，一进家庭办公室，就看到罗伯特·万毫无反应地躺在展开的沙发上。约瑟夫冲过去检查罗伯特的脉搏，发现有血从他的胸口渗出。他冲着惊慌失措尖叫的维克托大喊，让他报警。接着约瑟夫抓起一条毛巾按在罗伯特的伤口上。这番骚动吵醒了迪伦，他离开房间，发现维克托正在惊慌地打电话，
and Joseph in the office, holding a towel against Robert's chest. Dylan, still groggy from the sleeping pill, was confused by the situation before him. Six minutes later, an ambulance arrived. Robert's pajama top was slashed in three places. Underneath were three stab wounds to his chest. Robert had only been at the address for 90 minutes before he was rushed to hospital. He was pronounced to dead, shortly after midnight. There had been a recent spade of break-ins at homes within the DuPont Circle. In some instances, intruders had been brazen enough to enter properties while the residents were inside.
而约瑟夫则在办公室里，用毛巾按住罗伯特的胸口。迪伦被安眠药弄得晕乎乎的，对眼前的状况感到困惑。六分钟后，救护车赶到。罗伯特的睡衣上衣在三个地方被割破。下面是胸部的三个刺伤伤口。罗伯特到这个地址仅90分钟就被紧急送往医院。他在午夜后不久被宣告死亡。杜邦环岛内的住宅近期发生了一系列入室盗窃案。在某些情况下，闯入者胆大妄为，甚至在居民在家时闯入房产。
The police had only recently issued a security statement to locals, advising them to keep their doors locked at all times. Joseph Price failed to heed this warning on August 2. When detectives arrived at his Swan Street address that night, it was brought to their attention that the patio door was not only left unlocked, but was slightly ajar. The patio backed on to an alleyway that ran parallel to Swan Street Northwest, bordering the backs of all the row houses. This presented a likely scenario. An intruder had scaled the patio fence from the alley and gained access to the house via the unlocked door.
警方最近才向当地居民发布了一份安全声明，建议他们随时锁好门。约瑟夫·普赖斯在8月2日未能听从这一警告。当侦探们当晚赶到他的天鹅街住所时，他们注意到露台门不仅没锁，而且还微微敞开着。露台背靠一条与西北天鹅街平行的巷子，毗邻所有联排别墅的背面。这呈现了一种很有可能发生的情况：一名闯入者从巷子里爬上露台栅栏，通过未锁的门进入了房子。
The Swan Street Row House was an appealing target for any burglar. Worth well over a million dollars, the property contained flat screen televisions and laptop computers, among other high-priced goods. Upon entering the house through the rear patio door, there was a kitchen counter to the left. Sitting on top of this counter was a knife block, filled with black-handled knives. It appeared as though the intruder had grabbed a knife before proceeding further inside. At some point, they entered the home office and encountered Robert Juan. A kitchen knife from the knife block was found on a nightstand next to the sofa bed. It's blade caked in Robert's blood, chest hairs, and some fatty tissue.
天鹅街联排别墅对任何盗贼来说都是一个诱人的目标。该房产价值远超一百万美元，里面有纯平电视和笔记本电脑等高价物品。从后方露台门进入房子后，左边是一个厨房台面。这个台面上放着一个刀架，里面插满了黑柄刀。看起来闯入者在深入屋内之前顺手拿了一把刀。在某个时刻，他们进入了家庭办公室并遇到了罗伯特·万。沙发床旁边的床头柜上发现了一把来自刀架的厨房刀。刀刃上结满了罗伯特的血迹、胸毛和一些脂肪组织。
The lack of foreign fingerprints on the knife or anywhere else throughout the property suggested that the intruder had worn gloves. Robert's final moments were pieced together from evidence at the scene and statements from the other occupants of the house. Robert had prepared for bed in his usual tidy way. He removed his work clothes and folded them neatly on a desk with his other belongings. After sharing, he put on his pajamas, a t-shirt, underwear, and gym shorts. The last thing Robert did before going to sleep was insert his mouth guard, which prevented him from grinding his teeth. He was wearing the mouthpiece when first responders
刀上或其他任何地方都缺乏外源指纹，这表明闯入者戴了手套。罗伯特生命的最后时刻是通过现场证据和屋里其他人的供词拼凑起来的。罗伯特像往常一样整洁地准备睡觉。他脱下工作服，和他的其他随身物品一起整洁地叠在书桌上。洗完澡后，他穿上了睡衣、T恤、内衣和健身短裤。罗伯特睡觉前做的最后一件事是戴上他的护齿牙套，这可以防止他磨牙。急救人员到达时，他正戴着这个牙套。
arrived. Robert's killer stabbed him three times in the chest and abdomen. What provoked the attack was uncertain. It didn't seem likely that Robert was targeted specifically. His colleagues hadn't noticed anything different about him lately, and his kind demeanour meant it was unlikely he was the target of a murderous vendetta. A case of mistaken identity didn't add up either. There was nothing in Joseph, Victor, or Dylan's lifestyles that indicated any of them could have been the intended victim. None had a criminal history, and all were well regarded for their career success and philanthropy. The three men spoke willingly to police and provided their fingerprints,
罗伯特的凶手在他的胸部和腹部捅了三刀。是什么引发了这起袭击尚不确定。罗伯特似乎并非被特定针对的目标。他的同事最近没有注意到他有什么异常，而且他温和的为人意味着他不太可能是谋杀性血海深仇的目标。身份认同错误的情况也说不通。约瑟夫、维克托或迪伦的生活方式中没有任何迹象表明他们中的任何一人可能是预期的受害者。没有人有犯罪记录，并且都因其职业成功和慈善事业而广受好评。这三个男人自愿与警方交谈，并提供了他们的指纹、
hair samples, and DNA. They were open and candid when answering questions, and when spoken to separately, their stories aligned. Yet, there was one aspect of the men's lives that investigators honed in on, their sexuality and the nature of their relationships with one another. The men openly discussed their roles in each other's lives, which amounted to them being in a three-way polyamorous relationship. It started with Joseph and Victor, registered domestic partners who had been together for six years. Dylan entered the picture as the couple's roommate before engaging in his own intimate relationship with Joseph. There was a malleable aspect to the group's arrangement, which was
头发样本和DNA。他们在回答问题时坦诚直率，而且在分别接受询问时，他们的说辞完全一致。然而，这些男人的生活中有一个方面是调查人员关注的焦点，那就是他们的性取向以及他们彼此之间的关系性质。这几个男人公开讨论了他们在彼此生活中的角色，也就是他们处于一种三人多边恋关系中。这段关系始于约瑟夫和维克托，他们是已经在一起六年的注册家庭伴侣。迪伦作为这对伴侣的室友进入了他们的生活，随后与约瑟夫发展了亲密关系。这个群体的安排具有某种灵活性，并且
developing over time. All three men accepted and consented to their circumstances, describing themselves as a family. Yet, their lifestyle was of interest to investigators who questioned where Robert Juan fit in to their unconventional relationship. The police interviews with Joseph, Victor, and Dylan were later criticized by some for being, quote, homophobic, brow-beating. Without a clear motive or suspect, interviewing officers set out to prove that Robert Juan was gay to establish some or all of the Swan Street residents as potential suspects. Yet, all three men denied having a sexual relationship with Robert. He was, by all accounts, exclusively heterosexual and happily married.
随着时间推移在不断发展。这三个男人都接受并同意了他们的生活状况，称自己为一个家庭。然而，他们的生活方式引起了调查人员的兴趣，调查人员质疑罗伯特·万如何融入他们这种非传统的关系中。警察对约瑟夫、维克托和迪伦的审讯后来被一些人批评为“恐同”、“霸凌”。在没有明确动机或嫌疑人的情况下，审讯警官着手证明罗伯特·万是同性恋，以确立部分或全部天鹅街居民为潜在嫌疑人。然而，这三个男人都否认与罗伯特有性关系。根据所有人的说法，他完全是异性恋，并且婚姻幸福。
During Dylan Ward's interview, he was asked, Robert's perfectly straight and he's going to leave his wife for the night and come over to you all's house. Dylan attempted to defend himself against the inflammatory remark, retorting, yeah, because, but was immediately cut off by the officer who said, then he's not perfectly straight. That's not something a straight guy would do. In Joseph Price's interview, he insisted that Robert was not gay, never had been, or ever thought about it. He described Robert as the most straight A no-nonsense guy he had ever met. He didn't take drugs or drink alcohol to excess. Others felt this line of inquiry was not
在对迪伦·沃德的审讯中，有人问他：“罗伯特绝对是直男，他要离开妻子一晚，然后来你们所有人的房子。”迪伦试图为自己辩护以反击这种煽动性的言论，反驳道：“对，因为，但立刻被警官打断说：“那他就不完全是直男。直男是不会做这种事的。”在对约瑟夫·普赖斯的审讯中，他坚称罗伯特不是同性恋，从来都不是，也从未考虑过。他形容罗伯特是他见过的最直、最踏实、最不胡闹的人。他不吸毒，也不酗酒。其他人觉得这种调查方向
bigoted, just aggressive. They believed a possible romantic link between Robert and any one of the others was a reasonable lead worth investigating. After Robert Warn's murder, the Swan Street Northwest row house was left ravaged of its former glory. Through their process of collecting forensic evidence, police had caused thousands of dollars worth of damage to the property. Joseph, Victor, and Dylan no longer wanted to live there, but were forced to stay while repairs were undertaken so that the house could be sold. And their worries had only just begun. Barely two months after Robert was murdered, Joseph, Victor, and Dylan returned to their home to find it in disarray. Seven thousand dollars worth of items had been stolen,
并非出于偏见，只是比较激进。他们认为罗伯特与其他人之间可能存在的浪漫联系是一个值得调查的合理线索。罗伯特·万遇害后，西北天鹅街的联排别墅昔日的辉煌荡然无存。在收集法医证据的过程中，警方对该物业造成了价值数千美元的破坏。约瑟夫、维克托和迪伦不想再住在那里，但为了能卖掉房子，在进行维修期间他们被迫留下来。而他们的烦恼才刚刚开始。罗伯特遇害后仅仅两个月，约瑟夫、维克托和迪伦回到家中，发现家里一片狼藉。价值七千美元的物品被盗，
including a flat screen television and other electronics. An arrest swiftly followed. To the shock of many, one of the two people accused of the burglary was Michael Price, Joseph's brother. Michael had a substance abuse problem and had stolen from the three men before. This raised the question, did Michael break in on August 2 and perhaps not expecting to come across a stranger in the home office, kill Robert Warn? Michael was a student and had missed his classes on the night of Robert's murder. He also had a key to his brother's house. Nothing was uncovered that directly linked Michael to Robert, but he would remain a person of interest in the homicide investigation. As for the burglary months later, the charges against
其中包括一台平板电视和其他电子产品。随后迅速实施了逮捕。令许多人震惊的是，被指控盗窃的两名嫌疑人之一是约瑟夫的兄弟迈克尔·普赖斯。迈克尔有药物滥用问题，以前曾偷过这三个男人的东西。这就引发了一个问题：迈克尔是否在8月2日闯入，也许是没有料到会在家庭办公室里遇到一个陌生人，从而杀害了罗伯特·万？迈克尔是一名学生，在罗伯特遇害当晚缺课了。他还有他兄弟家钥匙。没有发现任何直接将迈克尔与罗伯特联系起来的证据，但他仍将作为凶杀案调查的关注对象。至于几个月后的盗窃案，对
Michael and his co-accused were ultimately dropped during a pretrial hearing. Then came another unexpected turn of events. Joseph Price, Victor Zaborsky, and Dylan Ward all hired distinguished legal representation and ceased speaking with authorities about the Robert Warn case. There was a good reason for their change of heart. The two paramedics who responded to Victor Zaborsky's 911 call on the night of Robert's murder were very proficient, with 25 years' experience between them. Both had been to their share of violent scenes, including stabbings. However, as they entered the Swan Street northwest row house, they were greeted with a sight neither had seen before. One of the paramedics later said that
迈克尔及其同案被告的指控最终在审前听证会上被撤销。接着又出现了另一个意料之外的转折。约瑟夫·普赖斯、维克托·扎博尔斯基和迪伦·沃德都聘请了杰出的法律代表，并停止就罗伯特·万案与当局对话。他们改变主意是有充分理由的。在罗伯特遇害当晚响应维克托·扎博尔斯基911报警的两名医护人员经验非常丰富，两人都有25年的工作经验。他们都处理过各自份额的暴力现场，包括刺伤事件。然而，当他们进入西北天鹅街联排别墅时，眼前的景象是两人从未见过的。其中一名医护人员后来表示，
the actions of Joseph, Victor, and Dylan were enough to make the hairs on the back of their neck stand up. After the paramedics received reports of a stabbing at the Swan Street northwest row house, it took them six minutes to reach the property. Victor Zaborsky met them on the front steps in a white bathrobe. He was crying into a cell phone which was still connected to emergency services. What's going on, one of the paramedics asked him, so which Victor explained that the stabbing victim was on the second floor. They entered the house carrying a stretcher and immediately made their way upstairs, where they came across Dylan Ward. He too was dressed in a white bathrobe.
约瑟夫、维克托和迪伦的行为足以让他们的汗毛直竖。医护人员接到西北天鹅街联排别墅发生刺伤事件的报告后，花了六分钟抵达现场。维克托·扎博尔斯基穿着一件白色浴袍在台阶前迎接他们。他正对着一个仍连接着紧急服务部门的手机哭泣。“到底怎么了？”其中一名医护人员问他，维克托随即解释说，被刺伤的受害者在二楼。他们抬着担架走进屋里，径直上楼，遇到了迪伦·沃德。他同样穿着一件白色浴袍。
They asked Dylan the same question. He pointed down the hall without saying a word. Then he silently retreated into his bedroom and closed the door. Dylan's complete lack of emotion confused the paramedics. They had never seen such cool indifference from someone at an active crime scene. Come to think of it, the paramedics noticed an uncharacteristic and eerie quietness throughout the entire residence that didn't add up to the urgency or brutality of what had happened there. Inside the home office was Joseph Price, sitting on the fold-out sofa with his back to the door and with one leg tucked beneath him. He was naked aside from a pair of underwear. He wasn't touching Robert Wahn or making any effort to render aid
他们问了迪伦同样的问题。他一言不发地指了指走廊。然后他默默地退回自己的卧室并关上了门。迪伦完全缺乏情绪的表现让医护人员感到困惑。他们从未在一个正在处理的犯罪现场看到过如此冷漠的人。回想起来，医护人员注意到整个住宅内有一种不合常理的怪异安静，这与那里发生的事件的紧急程度或残酷性完全不符。在家庭办公室里，约瑟夫·普赖斯背对门坐在展开的沙发上，一条腿蜷在身下。除了穿一条内衣外，他赤身裸体。他没有触碰罗伯特·万，也没有做出任何施以援手或帮助的努力。
or assistance. When asked what was going on, Joseph simply replied, I heard a scream. Then he stood and moved out of the paramedics' way. The lead medic rushed to Robert while the other edged around the sofa to get a better look at Joseph. His ill-fitting behavior made them uneasy and they wanted to keep him in their line of sight. They even eyed his hands in case he was carrying a weapon. While the resident's version of events as detailed at the beginning of this episode indicated the attack happened quickly and recently, Robert appeared to have been deceased for some time. He was unresponsive, pale, had no pulse, and was cold to the touch. His eyes were fixed and
当被问及发生了什么时，约瑟夫简单地回答：“我听到了一声尖叫。”然后他站起身，从医护人员让出路来。首席医护人员冲向罗伯特，而另一人则绕过沙发以更好地观察约瑟夫。他不得体的行为让他们感到不安，他们想将他保持在视线范围内。他们甚至盯着他的手，以防他携带武器。虽然正如本集开头所详述的那样，居民们对事件版本的描述表明袭击发生得很快且就在最近，但罗伯特看起来已经死亡一段时间了。他没有反应，脸色苍白，没有脉搏，触感冰冷。他的眼睛固定且
dilated. There was no blood seeping from the three wounds in his chest, even though they were big enough to, quote, fit your finger into. According to Joseph, when he lifted Robert's shirt upon finding the man unconscious, he saw blood everywhere. He claimed to have attempted to staunch the bleeding using a towel, explaining that there was a lot of blood on the bed. The knife had pierced Robert's heart, chest wall, right lung, small intestine, and pancreas. The resulting injuries should have caused a catastrophic amount of bleeding, as Joseph had described. However, there were no copious bloodstains or spatter on or around Robert, aside from two unusually small spots on the sheet beneath him.
散大。胸部的三个伤口没有血渗出，尽管它们大到“可以把手指塞进去”。据约瑟夫所说，当他在发现男子失去意识时掀起罗伯特的衬衫时，他看到到处都是血。他声称曾试图用毛巾止血，并解释说床上有大量的血。刀刺穿了罗伯特的心脏、胸壁、右肺、小肠和胰腺。由此产生的伤口本应导致灾难性的大量出血，正如约瑟夫所描述的那样。然而，除了他身下的床单上有两个异常小的斑点外，罗伯特身上或周围没有大量的血迹或喷溅痕迹。
It was believed these were caused when the paramedics rolled his body onto the stretcher. Either way, the amount of blood in the room was entirely inconsistent with a violent stabbing having taken place there. Robert's blood was also discovered in minimal amounts on a black-handled kitchen knife found on the nightstand and a large white cotton towel on the floor. While the towel hinted at someone endeavoring to staunch Robert's bleeding, paramedics noticed something that suggested a completely different act had taken place. A light film across Robert's torso featured the type of markings that would be visible if someone had attempted to clean the area with the towel, not stabilize it. As for the bloody towel on the floor,
据信，这些斑点是医护人员将他的身体滚动到担架上时产生的。无论哪种情况，房间里的血流量都与那里发生过暴力刺伤事件完全不符。在床头柜上发现的一把黑柄厨房刀和地板上的一条大白棉毛巾上，也仅发现了少量的罗伯特血迹。虽然毛巾暗示有人在努力阻止罗伯特流血，但医护人员注意到了一些表明曾发生过完全不同行为的事情。罗伯特躯干上的一层薄膜具有某种痕迹，如果有人试图用毛巾清洁该区域而不是稳定它，就会看到这种痕迹。至于地上的血毛巾，
the staining was more consistent with someone having used it to wipe the sharp edge of a knife clean. More than 10 white fibers consistent with the towel were found in the blood on the knife, but there were no fibers from or consistent with Robert's torn shirt. The knife was absent of blood along the cutting edge, but blood ran the entire length of its blade, which measured five and a half inches. Robert's wounds were only four to five inches deep. While the knife contained no foreign DNA or fingerprints, Joseph Price informed police that his might be found. He explained that when he first came across Robert, the knife was lying on his stomach, so he moved it aside to render first aid. When speaking about the incident to a friend
上面的污渍更符合有人用它擦拭刀刃边缘的情况。在刀上的血迹中发现了10多根与毛巾相符的白色纤维，但没有来自或符合罗伯特被撕裂衬衫的纤维。刀的切割边缘没有血迹，但血迹贯穿了整条刀刃，刀刃长五点五英寸。罗伯特的伤口只有四到五英寸深。虽然刀上没有外源DNA或指纹，但约瑟夫·普赖斯告知警方可能会找到他的DNA。他解释说，当他第一次遇到罗伯特时，刀正躺在他的肚皮上，所以他把它移开以进行急救。后来在与朋友谈论这起事件时，
later, Joseph would say that he had physically pulled the weapon out of Robert's chest before placing it on the nightstand. Joseph volunteered that the police might not find the real killer's DNA on the knife because they might have been, quote, wearing a glove. Yet, it was determined that the knife at the crime scene was highly unlikely to have produced wounds the size and shape of Robert's. As for the guest room itself, there was no sign of a struggle having taken place there. While this implied Robert was attacked mid-sleep, such a scenario didn't correlate with the condition of the sofa bed. Robert's head rested on a fluffed, clean pillow with only one indentation, meaning his head hadn't moved at all since falling asleep.
约瑟夫曾说他曾亲手将凶器从罗伯特的胸口拔出，然后放在床头柜上。约瑟夫自愿表示，警察可能在刀上找不到真凶的DNA，因为他们可能“戴着手套”。然而，经确定，现场的刀极不可能产生罗伯特伤口大小和形状的伤痕。至于客房本身，没有发生过挣扎的迹象。虽然这暗示罗伯特是在睡梦中遭到袭击的，但这种设想与沙发床的情况并不相符。罗伯特的头部靠在一个蓬松干净的枕头上，只有一个凹痕，这意味着自从入睡以来他的头部根本没有动过。
His wounds were uniform in shape and size, which is unusual in stubbing cases, as victims tend to thrash around, creating varying injuries. The fatal wound effectively shut down Robert's heart, but none of his wounds would have killed or rendered him unconscious immediately. He would have been alive for between 60 seconds to 10 minutes before succumbing to the type of injuries he had endured. It was odd that his body had remained in one position that entire time. He hadn't tried to defend himself or reacted in any other way. He just lay there, unmoving, even when someone was thrusting a knife into his chest. A medical examiner noted,
他的伤口形状和大小均一，这在刺伤案件中很不寻常，因为受害者往往会挣扎，从而造成不同的伤害。致命伤有效地关闭了罗伯特的心脏，但他的任何伤口都不会立即致死或让他失去意识。在屈服于他所遭受的此类伤害之前，他会存活60秒到10分钟。奇怪的是，他的身体在那整个时间里保持在一个位置。他没有试图保护自己，也没有做出任何其他反应。他就那样躺着，一动不动，甚至当有人把刀刺进他的胸膛时也是如此。法医指出，
The wounds and internal bleeding would have produced such extreme pain that it would have been virtually impossible for Mr. Wan to have refrained from moving his body while in the bed or attempting to get out of the bed to seek help. The lack of any movement from Robert was even more suspicious, considering the DC area was experiencing a heat wave. According to Kathy Wan, Robert was particularly self-conscious about sweating in his sleep. He would toss and turn and kick blankets away for relief, but the sofa didn't appear to have been slept in at all. The top sheets and covers were neatly folded down at a 45 degree angle under Robert's body,
伤口和内出血会产生如此极端的疼痛，以至于万先生几乎不可能在床上保持身体不动，或者试图起床寻求帮助而不做任何移动。考虑到华盛顿特区地区正在经历热浪，罗伯特没有任何移动就更可疑了。据凯茜·万称，罗伯特对自己在睡梦中出汗特别在意。他会辗转反侧并踢开毯子来解暑，但沙发看起来一点也没有被睡过的痕迹。上层床单和被子在罗伯特身体下方以45度角整齐地折叠着，
which was how his hosts had described preparing the sofa for him. Robert wasn't known to sleep this way. Even if he did, the bedding shared the same level of preservation as the pillow, as if Robert didn't move in the slightest at all after settling onto the bed. There were no defensive wounds whatsoever on Robert's body. A medical examiner concluded, Robert would have reacted instinctively to protect himself and or physically fend off his attacker, unless he was, quote, otherwise incapacitated. While there were no markings to suggest that Robert had been manually strangled, hemorrhaging in his left eye meant some type of asphyxiation had occurred.
这正是他的主人描述为他准备沙发的方式。罗伯特不习惯这样睡觉。即使他真的这样睡了，床铺也保持着与枕头相同的平整度，就好像罗伯特在躺下后一点也没有动过一样。罗伯特的尸体上没有任何防御性伤口。法医总结道，罗伯特会出于本能地做出反应来保护自己和/或物理上击退攻击者，除非他“在其他方面失去了行动能力”。虽然没有任何痕迹表明罗伯特曾被人工勒死，但左眼的出血意味着发生了某种窒息。
It was theorized that Robert had been smothered unconscious with a pillow prior to being stabbed. Yet, small needle punctures were visible on the left side of Robert's neck. There were three more on his chest, two on his right foot, and one on the back of his left hand. There was no record of paramedics or hospital staff injecting Robert with anything. This meant that the puncture wounds were made before Robert was treated, while he was still alive. Tests for various alcohols, amphetamines, opiates, barbiturates, and benzodiazepine drugs, including commonly known date-rape drugs, came back negative. Remnants of ecstasy and cannabis were found in the row house, but did not show up in Robert's blood screen.
有一种理论认为，罗伯特在被刺前曾用枕头闷迷晕。然而，罗伯特左侧颈部可见细小的针孔。胸部还有三个，右脚两个，左手背一个。没有记录表明医护人员或医院工作人员给罗伯特注射过任何东西。这意味着这些针孔是在罗伯特接受治疗之前、他还活着的时候留下的。对各种酒精、安非他命、阿片类药物、巴比妥酸盐和苯二氮卓类药物（包括俗称的迷奸药）的检测结果均为阴性。在联排别墅中发现了摇头丸和大麻的残余物，但并未在罗伯特的血液筛查中显现。
By the time police arrived at the Swan Street address, Robert was being stretched into the waiting ambulance. Officers entered the house and immediately encountered all three male residents. Victor and Dylan were still in their white robes, and Joseph was still in his underwear. Joseph did all the talking. He said that they had been burglarized and pointed towards the patio door at the rear of the kitchen, remarking, See, the door is still open. Officer Diane Durham went to investigate. She noted that the door was all but a quarter of an inch closed. It was just touching the frame. According to Officer Durham, Joseph heard somebody scream and ran down to the ground floor.
当警方到达天鹅街住所时，罗伯特正被抬上等待的救护车。警官们进入屋里，立刻遇到了所有三名男性居民。维克托和迪伦仍穿着白色长袍，约瑟夫仍穿着内衣。约瑟夫包揽了所有谈话。他说他们遭到了入层盗窃，并指向厨房后方的露台门，评论道：“看，门还是开着的。”戴安·达勒姆警官前去调查。她注意到门几乎关上了四分之一英寸。它刚好碰到门框。据达勒姆警官称，约瑟夫听到有人尖叫并跑到了底楼。
In contrast to the story of Robert being discovered injured in bed, in this instance, Joseph claimed that Robert was actually outside the patio door bleeding. The others led him in and took him upstairs to lie on the sofa bed. Officer Durham advised Joseph to dress himself, as other units would be coming to investigate. Joseph then covered himself with a white robe. As more police arrived, the three residents were asked to remain in the living room, where they were observed whispering among themselves. It was noted that they all appeared to have showered recently. When asked again what had happened, Dylan Ward began to speak.
与罗伯特在床上被发现受伤的故事相反，在这种情况下，约瑟夫声称罗伯特实际上是在露台门外流血。其他人把他拉进来，并把他带到楼上躺在沙发床上。达勒姆警官建议约瑟夫穿好衣服，因为其他单位将会来调查。然后约瑟夫用一件白色长袍把自己裹起来。随着更多警察到达，三名居民被要求留在起居室里，在那里观察到他们在窃窃私语。据注意到，他们看起来都刚洗过澡。当再次被问及发生了什么事时，迪伦·沃德开始说话。
Joseph immediately shot him a forbidding stare, causing Dylan to fall silent. Joseph once again rehashed the events of the night. He reiterated that they had been woken by the door chime. Joseph theorized that an unknown intruder had scaled the patio fence, then entered and exited the house via the door he had accidentally left unlocked. Curiously, the residents had only heard the chime once, suggesting someone entered, but didn't leave. Furthermore, the tenant who lived separately in the Roe Houses basement had spoken to Joseph earlier that night. She was going to spend the night at a friend's house.
约瑟夫立即向他投去严厉的一瞥，迪伦顿时哑口无言。约瑟夫再次复述了当晚的经过。他重申，他们是被门铃声吵醒的。约瑟夫推测，一个不知名的入侵者翻过了露台围栏，然后通过他无意中忘锁的门进入并离开了房屋。奇怪的是，居民们只听到了一次门铃声，这表明有人进来却没出去。此外，住在罗伊住宅地下室的那个单住租客当晚早些时候曾与约瑟夫交谈过。她打算在朋友家过夜。
Shortly before she left at 6pm, she called Joseph and told him that she had set the security alarm, one that would have made a loud commotion if someone broke into the house. This meant it had been deactivated during the night. In their statements to police in the immediate aftermath of the murder, the Roe Houses occupants would state that the security alarm was not engaged that night. Joseph then led the police on a tour of his home. As officers ascended the stairs to the second and third floors, they noticed how loud their steps were on the wooden floorboards.
在她于傍晚6点离开之前，她打电话给约瑟夫，告诉他她已经设置了安全警报，如果有人闯入房屋，警报会发出巨大的声响。这意味着警报在夜间被解除激活了。在谋杀案发生后立即向警方做出的陈述中，罗伊住宅的居住者们声称当晚安全警报并未开启。随后，约瑟夫带领警方参观了他的家。当警官们顺着楼梯登上二楼和三楼时，他们注意到木制地板上的脚步声是多么清晰响亮。
None of the residents recalled hearing the intruder's footsteps. Not even Dylan, whose bedroom was at the top of the stairs and needed to be passed in order to reach the home office. Joseph told officers that Dylan might have slept through the attack because the air conditioner was on and the compressor on the roof above Dylan's bedroom was very loud. When officers tested this theory, they could barely hear the compressor, calling the noise imperceptible. Despite the residents' claims, the situation didn't seem like a burglary gone wrong. The interior of the Roe House was neat and orderly. Expensive electronics were in their usual spots. Nothing was missing. Even Robert's wallet,
没有一个居民回忆听到入侵者的脚步声。甚至连迪伦也没有，他的卧室就在楼梯顶端，必须经过那里才能到达家庭办公室。约瑟夫告诉警官们，迪伦可能是因为开着空调而睡过了整场袭击，因为迪伦卧室上方屋顶上的压缩机声音非常大。当警官们测试这一理论时，他们几乎听不到压缩机发出的声音，可以说是微不可闻。尽管居民们信誓旦旦，但情况看起来并不像是一起失控的入室盗窃案。罗伊住宅的内部整洁有序。昂贵的电子产品都放在它们通常的位置。什么东西都没丢。甚至罗伯特的钱包、
watch and blackberry phone were still in the home office, on the desk with his work clothes. Joseph and Victor told police that their Swan Street residents had never been burglarized before, or even entered by an intruder. They as well as Dylan ultimately acknowledged that the intruder theory was implausible and made absolutely no sense. But all three steadfastly maintained it. Their recollections of the night mostly aligned, and their statements were also suspiciously specific. For investigators, this indicated they had coached each other on what to say beforehand. Curiously, they glossed over some key details, such as their friendship with Robert. They minimized it to the point where it seemed like they were distant friends at most,
手表和黑莓手机依然放在家庭办公室里，就在摆着他工作服的书桌上。约瑟夫和维克托告诉警方，他们的天鹅街住所以前从未遭人入室盗窃过，甚至连入侵者都没进过。他们以及迪伦最终承认，入侵者理论根本站不住脚，完全不合逻辑。但他们三人都坚决咬定这一说法。他们对当晚的回忆大体一致，而且他们的供词也具体得可疑。对于调查人员来说，这表明他们在事前就如何说辞进行了串供。奇怪的是，他们对一些关键细节轻描淡写，比如他们与罗伯特的友谊。他们将其轻描淡写到这种程度：看起来他们最多也就是泛泛之交，
and old acquaintances at least. This didn't align with the fact that the trio had hosted Robert's 30th birthday party years earlier. Joseph and Victor had attended his wedding, and Robert would catch up with them periodically, sometimes multiple times a year. Despite their inability to remember something as significant as their long-term friendship with Robert, the trio recalled unremarkable details with a suspicious amount of detail, such as how Joseph had gone outside to investigate the spider on the patio light, which led to him leaving the door unlocked. Once interviewing officers sensed things weren't adding up, they started to record the three men. At any given time in their recollections,
最少也就是老相识。这与事实不符——这三人几年前曾主办过罗伯特的30岁生日派对。约瑟夫和维克托出席了他的婚礼，罗伯特会定期与他们聚会，有时一年好几次。尽管他们记不清与罗伯特长期友谊这样的大事，但这三人却能以令人怀疑的详细程度回忆起一些微不足道的细节，比如约瑟夫是如何走到户外去查看露台灯上的蜘蛛，这导致他忘记锁门。一旦讯问警官察觉到事情不对劲，他们就开始对这三名男子进行录音。在他们回忆的任何特定时刻，
there were moments in which one or several of the men were unable to account for the others. Yet, no matter the line of questioning, all three were unwavering in their innocence, and staunchly defended one another. Joseph told officers, I know Victor and Dylan better than I know my mum. There is no chance on the face of the earth that anybody did anything to Robert. They couldn't even spank a child that was being bad. At one point during his interview, Joseph demanded, I want to see them both, referring to Victor and Dylan. He seemed most concerned with Dylan in particular. When told he was free to go, Joseph replied, What's the story with Dylan? I mean, I'm going to get his attorney to come down here.
总会有这样的时刻：其中一人或数人无法说明其他人在哪里。然而，无论警方如何盘问，这三人始终坚定不移地坚称自己无辜，并死力护着彼此。约瑟夫对警官们说：“我了解维克托和迪伦，甚至超过了我了解我妈。世界上绝无可能任何人对罗伯特做过任何事。他们连打不听话的小孩屁股都舍不得。”在讯问过程中的某个时刻，约瑟夫要求道：“我要见他们俩，”指的是维克托和迪伦。他对迪伦似乎尤其关心。当被告知他可以离开时，约瑟夫回答说：“迪伦是怎么回事？我的意思是，我要去找他的律师来这里。”
By now, police had well formed opinions of the trio. They described Joseph Price as arrogant, unconcerned, flippant, aggressive, and self-centered. His partner, Victor Zaborski, was passive, disinterested, and unconcerned about solving the attack, as was Dylan Ward, who was calm and distant. Following Robert Warn's murder, detectives meticulously canvassed the Swan Street row house for evidence. On one occasion, they watched as a cadaver dog trained to locate human blood and remains was led through the house. The dog ran through the open living space downstairs, nose to the ground, before being let out the back door to the patio. When he reached a drain cover at its center,
此时，警方对这三人的印象已经根深蒂固。他们将约瑟夫·普价（Joseph Price）形容为傲慢、漠不关心、轻率、好斗且以自我为中心。他的伴侣维克托·扎博斯基（Victor Zaborski）则表现得被动、兴致索然，对破案漠不关心，迪伦·沃德（Dylan Ward）也是如此，表现得冷静而疏离。罗伯特·沃恩谋杀案发生后，侦探们对天鹅街联排住宅进行了仔细的搜查以寻找证据。有一次，他们看着一只受过训练、能够搜寻人类血液和遗骸的尸体搜寻犬被牵着穿过房屋。警犬在楼下一楼开阔的生活区里奔跑，鼻子贴着地面，随后被带到通往后院露台的后门外。当它到达中央的一个排水沟盖时，
he stopped and indicated to the handler that he could smell blood. The handler approached the drain. The cover was slightly ajar and an uncoiled garden hose lay nearby. Given the rest of the house was presented so immaculately, the displaced hose was uncharacteristically sloppy. It looked as though it had been recently used. The cadaver dog also alerted at a clothes dryer on the second floor near Dylan's bedroom. It was empty, but police were developing a theory. The killer had hosed down their bloody clothes over the drain outside, before placing them in the dryer. Detectives also tested for blood in the home office that might not have been visible to the
它停了下来，向训犬员示意它能闻到血腥味。训犬员走近排水沟。沟盖微微敞开，附近放着一根未盘好的花园软管。鉴于房屋的其他部分被打理得一尘不染，这个移位的软管显得极其草率。它看起来像是最近才被使用过。这具尸体搜寻犬还在二楼迪伦卧室附近的衣物烘干机前发出了警报。烘干机是空的，但警方正在推导一个推论。凶手在外面排水沟旁用水管冲洗了血衣，然后把它们放进了烘干机里。侦探们还在家庭办公室里进行了肉眼可能无法察觉的血液检测。
naked eye. They sprayed a substance that revealed trace amounts of blood on the walls, floor, sofa bed and door frame. It indicated that a large-scale cleanup had taken place after Robert's murder, but before authorities were called to the scene. The entire home was very clean, with the captain of the violent crime unit later saying, A lot of evidence that we should have seen at the house. We didn't see. A search of Dylan Ward's room uncovered a three-piece cutlery box set designed to hold a carving knife, a large fork and a smaller knife. The smaller knife was missing. Detectives contacted the manufacturer, who sent out a duplicate. When compared to the wounds
他们喷洒了一种试剂，显现出墙壁、地板、沙发床和门框上有微量的血迹。这表明在罗伯特遇害后、但在当局被召至现场之前，这里曾进行过大规模的清理工作。整栋房子被打扫得一尘不染，暴力犯罪部门的负责人后来表示：“我们在屋里本该看到的很多证据，我们都没有看到。”对迪伦·沃德房间的搜查发现了一套三件套的餐具盒，原本设计用于存放一把切肉刀、一把大叉子和一把小刀。其中较小的那把刀不见了。侦探们联系了制造商，制造商寄来了一把复制品。与造成罗伯特·沃恩伤口的痕迹相比，
inflicted on Robert Warn, this knife was capable of causing very similar results. Dylan's room also contained a trove of items used for dominant and submissive sex acts, including shackles, chains with locks, metal collars, wrist and ankle restraints, clamps, hooks and mouth gags. He also had a collection of manuals on sato masochistic practices and books dedicated to the subject of inflicting pain or enslaving others for sexual gratification. Many of these texts contained passages highlighted by the reader. When these items were first discovered, Dylan was up front with detectives. He and Joseph engaged in BDSM. That was an acceptable explanation, but in the context of Robert Warn's murder,
这把刀完全能够造成非常相似的后果。迪伦的房间里还藏有一大批用于施虐和受虐性行为的物品，包括脚镣、带锁的铁链、金属项圈、手腕和脚踝束缚带、夹子、挂钩和口塞。他还收藏了有关虐恋实践的手册以及专门探讨为性快感而施加痛苦或奴役他人的书籍。这些文本中有许多被读者用荧光笔做过标记。当这些物品首次被发现时，迪伦对侦探们直言不讳。他和约瑟夫有进行BDSM。这是一个可以接受的解释，但在罗伯特·沃恩谋杀案的背景下，
police did wonder whether the items were used to restrain or smother Robert. Traces of semen were found on and around Robert's genitals. When tested, it produced a puzzling result. The semen belonged to Robert, but there was nothing to suggest he willingly participated in any sex acts the night of his murder. Among Dylan Ward's belongings was an electrical shockwave generator. This device, controlled by a second party, released electrical impulses capable of causing the target individual to ejaculate, even when sedated or under anesthetic. A search of Joseph Price's computer indicated that he and Dylan were familiar with this machine. On a fetish site that he belonged to, Joseph listed electro-torture as an activity that he and
警方不禁怀疑这些物品是否曾被用来束缚或闷死罗伯特。在罗伯特的生殖器上及其周围发现了精液痕迹。经检测，结果令人迷惑不解。精液属于罗伯特本人，但没有任何迹象表明他在遇害当晚自愿参与了任何性行为。在迪伦·沃德的物品中有一个电击波发生器。这个设备由第三方控制，能释放出足以让目标个体射精的电脉冲，即使在镇静或麻醉状态下也是如此。对约瑟夫·普赖斯电脑的搜索表明，他和迪伦对这台机器都很熟悉。在他所属的一个恋物癖网站上，约瑟夫将电击酷刑列为他和
Dylan enjoyed. Robert's semen was also found inside his own rectum, with authorities pointing out that, quote, there were many items and devices recovered from Dylan Ward's bedroom designed to be inserted into one's anal cavity. A medical examiner concluded, Taking all the evidence and circumstances into consideration, this finding is suggestive of Mr. Warn having been sexually assaulted. No foreign DNA was found on Robert. Unsurprising, given one of his treating paramedics was of the opinion that Robert had been stabbed, showered, redressed, and placed in bed. During his interview with police following the murder, Dylan mentioned reading before he went
迪伦喜欢的活动。罗伯特的直肠内也发现了罗伯特的精液，当局指出：“从迪伦·沃德的卧室中回收了许多旨在插入肛门腔的物品和设备。”法医得出结论：“综合考虑所有证据和情况，这一发现表明沃恩先生曾遭受性侵犯。”在罗伯特身上没有发现外源性DNA。这并不令人意外，因为其中一位对他进行救治的医护人员认为，罗伯特曾被刺伤、冲澡、重新穿好衣服并被安置在床上。在谋杀案发生后接受警方采访时，迪伦提到他在睡觉前曾看书。
to sleep. In his room, detectives found a New Yorker magazine open on the floor to an article titled, Late Works, Writers Confronting the End. It was accompanied by an illustration of renowned English playwright, poet, and actor, William Shakespeare, lying on his deathbed. His body was positioned in the same way that Robert Warn had been when he was found. The first line of the article read, Last words, recorded and treasured in the days when the deathbed was in the home have fallen from fashion, perhaps because most people spend their final hours in the hospital too drugged to make any sense. It was months before police publicly named Joseph Price, Victor Zaborsky, and Dylan Ward as suspects
在他的房间里，侦探们发现一本翻开的《纽约客》杂志扔在地毯上，翻开的那页文章标题为《迟来的作品：作家们直面终结》。文章配有一幅著名的英国剧作家、诗人和演员威廉·莎士比亚躺在临终床榻上的插图。他的身体姿势与罗伯特·沃恩被发现时的姿势一模一样。文章的第一行写道：“临终遗言，在床榻设在家中的年代里被记录并珍视，如今已不再流行，也许是因为大多数人在生命的最后几小时里都在医院度过，被药物麻痹得不省人事。”直到几个月后，警方才公开将约瑟夫·普赖斯、维克托·扎博斯基和迪伦·沃德列为谋杀罗伯特·沃恩的嫌疑人。
in the murder of Robert Warn. Their efforts were later criticized as sluggish and flawed, due to the abundance of circumstantial evidence implicating the three men from the get-go. Even the interrogation of the three suspects was considered sloppy. Far too much focus was placed on trying to establish a sexual relationship between one or all of the parties with Robert, despite this lead being completely unfounded. Anything compelling that should have been pressed harder, such as Joseph's two tales of where he apparently found the injured Robert, the patio, or the guest room, fell by the wayside. By the time police zeroed in on Joseph, Victor, and Dylan, the men had alloyed up and were no longer cooperating.
他们的侦办工作后来因行动迟缓且漏洞百出而受到批评，因为从一开始就有大量间接证据将这三名男子牵连其中。甚至对这三名嫌疑人的审讯也被认为十分草率。尽管这一线索完全毫无根据，但警方却把过多的精力放在试图确立其中一人或所有人与罗伯特之间存在性关系上。任何本该加大力度盘问的令人信服的线索，例如约瑟夫关于他 aparentemente 在哪里找到受伤的罗伯特的两种说法——露台还是客房——都付诸东流了。当警方最终将目标锁定在约瑟夫、维克托和迪伦身上时，这几名男子已经请好了律师，不再配合调查。
Detectives now believed that either two or all of the men committed the murder, or knew who did, and were covering for them. All they needed was a motive. Yet things continued to move at a slow pace. A year passed without any concrete leads that could result in an arrest, or better still, a conviction. The case was passed between three different prosecutors, and evidence from the row house was still being processed. A $25,000 reward was offered by police for information and led to plenty of tips, but the money was never handed out. Kathy Warn had so far grieved for her husband in private and kept away from the media. But she was compelled to step forward. In a statement printed in the Washington Post,
侦探们现在认为，要么是其中两名男子或全部三人犯下了谋杀案，要么就是他们知道凶手是谁并在包庇对方。他们所需要的只是一个动机。然而，案件进展依然缓慢。一年过去了，没有任何能够据此实施逮捕、或者更确切地说是定罪的具体线索。该案先后经手了三位不同的检察官，来自联排住宅的证据仍在处理中。警方悬赏25,000美元征集线索，虽然收到了大量举报，但奖金从未发放过。凯茜·沃恩此前一直在私下哀悼丈夫，并远离媒体。但她觉得自己不得不站出来。在《华盛顿邮报》刊登的一份声明中，
Kathy said, anything short of full and complete cooperation is very troubling, and essentially is equivalent of helping Robert's killer or killers get away with this terrible crime. She also described how she had coped with her husband's murder. During this year of intense sadness, I learned that being still and letting grief interrupt whenever it wished was oftentimes the best thing I could do for myself. When grief barges in and demands a visit, it's best to let her have your undivided attention. Frustrated by the lack of progress, Kathy held a press conference around the one-year anniversary of Robert's murder.
凯茜表示：“任何未能全面彻底配合的行为都令人深感不安，本质上就等于是在协助罗伯特的凶手或凶手们逃脱这起可怕的罪行。”她还描述了自己是如何应对丈夫遇害的。在这一年极度悲伤的日子里，我了解到，保持平静并任由悲伤在任何它想出现的时候打断自己，往往是我能为自己做的最好的事情。当悲伤闯入并要求拜访时，最好把你的全副注意力都留给它。由于对案件进展缓慢感到沮丧，凯茜在罗伯特遇害一周年之际举行了一场新闻发布会。
Her lawyer fielded questions from reporters about the investigation and the alleged involvement of Joseph Price, Victor Zaborski, and Dylan Ward. Kathy had a message for Robert's killer. Her choice of words seemed personal, as though she had her own suspicions as to who was responsible. Having a murder under conscience is no smaller thing to carry as you try to live, I imagine, as normal a life is possible. Confessing will be the hardest thing that you'll ever do in your life. Our laws will impose severe consequences,
她的律师回答了记者关于调查进展以及约瑟夫·普赖斯、维克托·扎博斯基和迪伦·沃德涉案指控的提问。凯茜给罗伯特的凶手留下了话。她用词的选择似乎带有个人色彩，仿佛她对谁是凶手有着自己的怀疑。我想，在试图过上尽可能正常的生活时，心里背负着一桩命案并不是一件轻松的事情。自首将是你一生中所做过最艰难的事情。我们的法律会施加严厉的后果，
but it will also be the most frightening thing that you can do for yourself. A secret like the one you are hiding from the world will only grow heavier at this time. As the two-year anniversary of Robert Warn's murder neared in June 2008, Joseph Price sold his Swan Street northwest row house for just under $1.5 million. He and Victor Zaborski moved to a rental nearby and planned to buy a house in Florida. Dylan Ward, who had already moved to Florida and obtained work as a massage therapist, was set to move in with the two men once they arrived. But their plans were disrupted just four months later when Dylan was arrested and charged with
但这也是你能为自己做的最令人畏惧的事情。你向世界隐瞒的这样一个秘密，在这个时候只会变得越来越沉重。随着2008年6月罗伯特·沃恩遇害两周年的临近，约瑟夫·普赖斯以不到150万美元的价格卖掉了他在西北天鹅街的联排住宅。他和维克托·扎博斯基搬到了附近的一处出租屋，并计划在佛罗里达州买一套房子。迪伦·沃德已经搬到了佛罗里达州并找到了一份按摩师的工作，等两人一到，他就准备和他们住在一起。但仅仅四个月后，他们的计划就被打乱了，因为迪伦被捕并被指控犯有
obstruction of justice. Although there wasn't enough evidence to charge him with murder, elements of the crime scene had been tampered with, suggesting a cover-up. An affidavit released days later stated, The evidence demonstrates that Robert Warn was restrained, incapacitated, sexually assaulted, and murdered. Given that Joseph and Victor were in a long-term domestic partnership, police zeroed in on Dylan Ward. They saw him as the weak link. Dylan didn't share the same longevity and loyalty to the others,
妨碍司法公正罪。尽管没有足够的证据指控他谋杀，但犯罪现场的某些部分曾被篡改，这表明存在掩盖罪行的行为。几天后发布的一份宣誓书指出：“证据表明，罗伯特·沃恩曾遭到束缚、失去行为能力、被性侵并被谋杀。”鉴于约瑟夫和维克托长期保持着家庭伴侣关系，警方将目光锁定了迪伦·沃德。他们视他为薄弱环节。迪伦不像其他人那样有着长期的伴侣关系和忠诚度，
leading detectives to suspect he'd be more likely to crack under pressure. They were wrong. Dylan continued to maintain that they were all innocent. He was ultimately jailed after failing to make bail. Prosecutors warned Joseph and Victor that their silence would result in a similar fate, and when their arrest warrants were issued a month later, the pair self-reported to authorities. All three men now faced charges for conspiracy, obstruction of justice, and tampering with evidence. The prosecution alleged that there was overwhelming evidence far in excess of probable cause, that they obstructed justice by altering and orchestrating the crime scene,
这让侦探们怀疑他在压力下更有可能崩溃。他们猜错了。迪伦坚称他们所有人都是无辜的。他在未能筹集保释金后最终被收监。检察官警告约瑟夫和维克托，保持沉默将导致同样的下场，一个月后，当针对二人的逮捕令下达时，两人向当局自首。现在，这三名男子都面临着阴谋罪、妨碍司法公正罪以及篡改证据罪的指控。检方辩称，有压倒性的证据远超合理怀疑标准，证明他们通过篡改和策划犯罪现场、
planting evidence, delaying the reporting of the murder to authorities, and lying to the police about the true circumstances of the murder. They all pleaded not guilty and were released to await trial, but subject to electronic monitoring and curfews. Joseph Price, Victor Zborski, and Dylan Ward faced trial in June 2010. They opted for a non-dury trial and invoked their Fifth Amendment right, meaning they would not have to testify. If found guilty, they faced prison sentences of up to 38 years. The group had hired a total of six defense attorneys, including a famous CNN commentator,
销毁证据、延迟向当局报告谋杀案以及向警方撒谎隐瞒谋杀案真相来妨碍司法公正。他们均不认罪，并被释放以等待审判，但须接受电子监控和宵禁。约瑟夫·普赖斯、维克托·扎博斯基和迪伦·沃德于2010年6月面临审判。他们选择进行无陪审团审判，并援引了美国宪法第五修正案赋予的权利，这意味着他们无需出庭作证。如果被判有罪，他们将面临长达38年的监禁。这群人总共聘请了六名辩护律师，其中包括一位著名的CNN评论员、
a former DC attorney general, and two former top DC prosecutors. They argued that their clients were unfairly targeted because they were gay and highlighted the sloppy police investigation. Quote, The government has cobbled together its case with tidbits of information that it interprets through innuendo and speculation, and then calls evidence. The defense's entire argument relied on the intruder theory. Prosecutors were unconvinced. Such a claim relied on an intruder deciding to break into the Swan Street row house on the exact night that Joseph happened to have left the patio door unlocked. Upon entering, the intruder
一位前哥伦比亚特区总检察长以及两位前哥伦比亚特区高级检察官。他们辩称，他们的当事人之所以成为不公正的目标，是因为他们是同性恋，并强调了警方调查的草率。引述：“政府通过将零星的信息拼凑在一起来构建其案件，这些信息是通过暗指和猜测来解读的，然后将其称为证据。”辩方的整个论点都建立在入侵者理论之上。检察官们并不买账。这种说法依赖于这样一个巧合：一个入侵者恰好在约瑟夫忘记锁露台门的那个夜晚决定闯入天鹅街的联排住宅。闯入后，入侵者
made no attempt to steal anything of value, including a laptop and television in view of the patio door. Instead, they grabbed a knife, walked through several areas to the front of the house, and immediately headed upstairs from there. Dylan Ward's bedroom was at the very top of the stairs, yet the intruder opted to turn 180 degrees and proceed down the hallway directly to the home office, the room furthest from the staircase. They entered, stabbed Robert, then cleaned the room of Bloodspatter so quietly that none of the other men in the house heard a thing. The intruder then fled, without even bothering to take Robert's small valuables such as his watch, cell phone, or wallet. They exited through the patio door,
没有试图盗窃任何有价值的东西，包括露台门正对视线内的一台笔记本电脑和一台电视机。相反，他们顺手拿了一把刀，穿过几个区域来到房屋前部，并直接从那里上楼。迪伦·沃德的卧室就在楼梯的最顶端，然而入侵者却选择转过180度，顺着走廊径直走向家庭办公室，那是距离楼梯最远的房间。他们走了进去，刺伤了罗伯特，然后把房间里的血迹清理得干干净净，动作极其安静，以至于屋里的其他男人什么都没听到。随后，入侵者逃跑了，甚至懒得拿走罗伯特的昂贵小物件，如手表、手机或钱包。他们从露台门离开，
scaled the fence, and escaped via the alleyway. All this happening within a 42-minute time frame. The Defences 42-minute time frame existed because of a series of emails sent from Robert's Blackberry on the night of August 2. When investigators initially examined the device, it appeared as though Robert emailed his wife at 11.05pm, informing her that he had just showered and was about to go to sleep. Two minutes later, he sent a second email to a friend regarding some lunch plans the following day. This meant he was confronted within the 42-minute window between sending this email and when Victor Zaborski phoned 911 at 11.49. But the emails were never sent. They were in a drafts folder. Investigators suspected that Robert didn't author the emails at all. Instead,
翻过围栏，通过小巷逃跑。所有这一切都发生在42分钟的时间窗口内。辩方提出的42分钟时间窗口之所以存在，是因为罗伯特的黑莓手机在8月2日晚发送了一系列电子邮件。当调查人员最初检查该设备时，似乎罗伯特在晚上11点05分给他妻子发了一封电子邮件，通知她他刚刚洗完澡，准备去睡觉。两分钟后，他给一位朋友发送了第二封电子邮件，讨论第二天的一些午餐计划。这意味着他在发送这封电子邮件与维克托·扎博斯基在11点49分拨打911之间的42分钟窗口内遭到了袭击。但这些电子邮件根本没有发送出去。它们存放在草稿箱里。调查人员怀疑罗伯特根本没有写过这些电子邮件。相反，
a perpetrator had crafted them to manipulate the supposed timeline of events. Robert's ordeal could have started much earlier. Assuming the emails were forged, the time frame for the assault and murder was 79 minutes, not 42. This allowed far more time for everything to take place before Victor Zaborski placed the 911 call. In Victor's call to 911, he continually used the pronoun we as in, we heard an intruder in the house. He was clearly speaking on behalf of others, suggesting a conversation had taken place between them before he placed the call. It wouldn't be the only time the trio had delayed calling authorities following a crime at their residence. When Michael Price burglarized the
是某个作案者精心炮制了它们，以操纵假定的事件时间线。罗伯特的遭遇可能发生得要早得多。假设这些电子邮件是伪造的，那么袭击和谋杀的时间窗口应该是79分钟，而不是42分钟。这就留出了更多的时间来完成这一切，然后维克托·扎博斯基才拨打911求救。在维克托拨打911的电话中，他一直使用代词“我们”，例如：“我们听到屋里有入侵者。”他显然是在代表其他人说话，这表明他在打电话之前曾与他们进行过交谈。这并不是这三人在住所发生犯罪后唯一一次延迟报警。当迈克尔·普赖斯在罗伯特谋杀案发生后几个月内入室盗窃该
address in the months after Robert's murder, Joseph convinced the others to wait a day before alerting the police. There was further evidence that supported the larger window of time theory, and it involved another witness. For the sake of clarity, we will refer to this witness as Sam. Sam lived next door to Joseph Price's row house. Their property shared an internal war with the home office where Robert had slept. On August 2, Sam was watching the 11pm news when they heard what they described as a single desperate scream. As Robert was incapacitated, authorities believed this scream came from Victor Zaborski, the only one of the three men to have shown any level of distress when first responders arrived. Victor had previously told police that he had screamed
地址时，约瑟夫说服其他人等了一天才报警。还有更多证据支持较大时间窗口理论，这涉及另一名证人。为了叙述清晰，我们将这位证人称为萨姆。萨姆住在约瑟夫·普赖斯联排住宅的隔壁。他们的房产与罗伯特睡觉的家庭办公室共用一堵内墙。8月2日，萨姆正在看晚上11点的新闻，这时他们听到了一声他们形容为绝望的尖叫。由于罗伯特已经失去反抗能力，当局认为这声尖叫来自维克托·扎博斯基，他是三名男子中唯一一个在急救人员抵达时表现出某种程度痛苦的人。维克托此前曾告诉警方，他曾因
upon seeing Robert's body. If Sam's recollections were correct, then this left a 19-49 minute window between Victor's alleged scream and him calling 911. From the prosecution's perspective, this gave the defendants enough time to clean up the crime scene, shower, and concoct a story to tell authorities. When Joseph ordered Victor to make the call, he told him to do so from upstairs, meaning the third floor, even though there was a phone right there in the home office. The proceedings felt like a murder trial, even though none of the accused had been charged with any such offense. Thirty witnesses were called on behalf of the prosecution compared to the defense's aide. The prosecution found the intruder scenario preposterous. They believed
看到罗伯特的尸体而尖叫。如果萨姆的回忆是准确的，那么这就留出了19到49分钟的时间窗口，介于维克托所谓的尖叫和拨打911之间。从检方的角度来看，这给了被告足够的时间来清理犯罪现场、洗澡并编造一套谎言来对付当局。当约瑟夫命令维克托打电话时，他叫维克托从楼上打，也就是三楼，尽管家庭办公室里就有一部电话。庭审过程感觉就像是一场谋杀审判，尽管没有一个被告被指控犯有此类罪行。检方传唤了30名证人，而辩方则传唤了8名。检方认为入侵者的设想荒谬绝伦。他们坚信
that at least one row house resident was responsible for Robert's assault and murder, and a second or third had participated or was an accomplice in the cover-up. Joseph Price was painted as the lead conspirator who manipulated Victor and Dylan through the use of money, influence, and power. The trio's intimate relationship ensured that they protected one another. Based on the type of sexual relationship Joseph and Dylan shared and their collection of adult toys, it appeared that either one or both had assaulted Robert. The fact that Joseph was near naked when first responders arrived hinted at his participation, though Joseph insisted he always slept in only his underwear. As Victor was the sole person to have had any emotional
至少有一名联排住宅的居民应对罗伯特的袭击和谋杀负责，第二或第三人则参与其中或是掩盖罪行的同谋。约瑟夫·普赖斯被刻画成主要的阴谋主使，他通过金钱、影响力和权力操纵了维克托和迪伦。三人之间亲密的伴侣关系确保了他们会互相庇护。基于约瑟夫和迪伦之间那种亲密的性关系以及他们收藏的成人玩具，情况似乎是其中一人或两人袭击了罗伯特。急救人员抵达时约瑟夫近乎赤身裸体，这一事实暗示了他参与其中，尽管约瑟夫坚称他睡觉时一向只穿内裤。由于维克托是唯一一个对罗伯特的谋杀做出任何情感
response to Robert's murder, some theorize he wasn't involved in the crime itself, but was an accomplice in covering it up. The prosecution's case was not a slam dunk. There were lots of aspects that were uncertain, inconsistent, circumstantial, or could be explained away. One example was the needle puncture marks found on Robert's body, hinting that he had been injected with a sedative. This was a major part of the prosecution's interpretation of the crime scene, yet a paramedic testified that she'd attempted to insert an IV into Robert's body in several spots. She was unsuccessful and her actions were not documented. Despite this, the judge found that some of the puncture marks did not align with those
反应的人，一些人推测他并未直接参与犯罪，而是协助掩盖罪行的同谋。检方的案件并非十拿九稳。有许多方面是不确定的、矛盾的、间接的，或者可以被勉强解释过去。一个例子是在罗伯特尸体上发现的针眼痕迹，暗示他被注射了镇静剂。这是检方对犯罪现场解读的重要部分，但一名医护人员作证称，她曾试图在罗伯特身体的几个部位插入静脉输液管。她没有成功，且她的这一操作没有被记录在案。尽管如此，法官还是认定其中一些针眼痕迹与
caused by medical intervention and was therefore confident that they had been caused during an assault. The investigation was plagued with a litany of other issues. Although crucial in determining the timeline of events, Robert's Blackberry phone had been completely lost. The device had apparently been given to the Secret Service who were going to copy its contents, but they denied ever receiving it. The blood-exposing product applied to the Home Office to reveal the cleanup effort was not applied as per the manufacturer's instructions. Consequently, this evidence was deemed unreliable. Robert's blood wasn't tested for all types of paralytic drugs. It is not known if the shockwave device among Dylan Ward's adult toys was tested
医疗干预造成的痕迹不符，因此确信它们是在袭击过程中造成的。调查工作饱受一连串其他问题的困扰。尽管对于确定事件时间线至关重要，但罗伯特的黑莓手机却彻底失踪了。该设备显然已被交给了特勤局，他们本打算复制其中的内容，但他们否认曾收到过它。用于家庭办公室以揭示清理工作的血迹显现试剂并未按照制造商的说明进行喷洒。因此，该证据被认为不可靠。罗伯特的血液未接受所有类型的麻痹药物检测。目前尚不清楚迪伦·沃德成人玩具中的电击波设备是否经过了
forensically. The lint trap from the dryer believed to have been used to dry the killer's clothes was not taken for analysis. The murder weapon was another contentious subject. The prosecution The prosecution presented evidence that the kitchen knife on the nightstand was not used to kill Robert. They believed Robert was stabbed with the missing knife from the cutlery set in Dylan Ward's room. But after a blood spatter expert for the defense described finding several of Robert's cut chest hairs on the kitchen knife, the judge was of the opinion that it was indeed the murder weapon. After nearly two weeks of defense testimony, the judge delivered a 35-page verdict. In the hour it took her to read it, she explained that she
法医鉴定。被认为曾用于烘干凶手衣物的烘干机绒毛收集网也未被取走进行分析。凶器是另一个有争议的话题。检方提交证据称，床头柜上的那把厨房刀并没有被用来杀死罗伯特。他们认为罗伯特是被迪伦·沃德房间餐具盒中不见的那把刀刺死的。但在辩方的血迹专家描述在厨房刀上发现了罗伯特几根被切断的胸毛后，法官认为这确实是凶器。经过近两周的辩护证词，法官宣读了一份长达35页的判决书。在她宣读判决所花的一个小时里，她解释说她
did not believe an intruder broke into the house, calling the circumstances suspicious and even damning. During a break in his initial police interview, Joseph had phoned his brother Michael and was overheard saying, Did Dylan come out? This led to the suspicion that Michael Price might have been involved in the crime. The trial judge admitted Michael's failure to attend class on the night of the murder was, quote, certainly worth pausing over in the circumstances of this case. But she was unconvinced that an outsider, including Michael, was responsible. The judge said that the charges came with what she called a math problem. That one or two of the defendants probably knew more than they were letting on. But it was also possible that at least
不相信有入侵者闯入过房屋，并称这种情况可疑甚至令人确凿。在最初的警方讯问的中场休息期间，约瑟夫曾打电话给他的兄弟迈克尔，并被无意中听到他说：“迪伦出来了吗？”这让人怀疑迈克尔·普赖斯可能卷入了这起犯罪。审判法官承认，迈克尔在谋杀案当晚没有去上课这件事，“在本地案件的情况下，确实值得让人停下来深思。”但她并不相信包括迈克尔在内的外人是凶手。法官表示，这些指控伴随着她所说的“数学难题”：一个或两个被告可能知道的比他们透露的要多。但也有可能至少
one might have been genuinely innocent of knowledge or involvement. But without the defendant's cooperation, determining who was the odd man out was nearly impossible. She went on to say the prosecution failed to prove that the three defendants covered up a murder, quote. My verdicts represent my effort to fairly and impartially follow the rule of law. My focus on the difference between moral certainty and evidentiary certainty in this case is probably cold comfort to those who loved Robert Wahn and wish for some measure of peace and justice, and I am extremely sorry for this. I believe, however, that the reasonable doubt standard is essential to maintaining our criminal justice system. I cite the wisdom of
其中一人可能确实对案情或参与情况一无所知。但在被告不予配合的情况下，要确定谁是局外人几乎是不可能的。她接着说，检方未能证明三名被告掩盖了一起谋杀。引述：“我的判决代表了我公平、公正地遵循法治的努力。我在本案中对道德确定性与证据确定性之间区别的关注，对于那些深爱罗伯特·沃恩并希望获得某种程度的平静与正义的人来说，可能只是微不足道的抚慰，对此我深表歉意。然而，我相信合理怀疑标准对于维护我们的刑事司法系统至关重要。我引用英国法学家威廉·布莱克斯通的名言：‘宁可纵容十个有罪的人，也不可冤枉一个无辜的人。’”
English jurist William Blackstone, that it is better that ten guilty persons escape than that one innocent suffer. Joseph Price, Victor Zaborsky and Dylan Ward were acquitted of all charges. Victor cried while Joseph and Dylan stared straight ahead, expressionless. The assistant US Attorney General respected the judge's decision and accepted her verdict, saying, everybody knew this was a challenging investigation and prosecution. Kathy Wahn, who had attended the trial daily with members of her husband's family, was led sobbing from the courtroom. For her, the case was particularly perplexing. Despite the acquitted having downplayed their friendship with her husband,
约瑟夫·普赖斯、维克托·扎博斯基和迪伦·沃德被判所有罪名不成立。维克托哭了，而约瑟夫和迪伦则面无表情地直视前方。美国助理检察长尊重法官的决定并接受了她的判决，称：“每个人都知道这是一次充满挑战的调查和起诉。”天天带着丈夫家属出席庭审的凯茜·沃恩被哭着扶出了法庭。对她而言，这个案件格外令人困惑。尽管被无罪释放的人曾淡化他们与她丈夫的友谊，
Joseph Price had been a pallbearer at Robert's funeral, a position reserved for those closest to him. In the aftermath of the trial, Kathy filed a wrongful death civil suit against Joseph, Victor and Dylan. In it, she alleged that the three men failed to rescue Robert after he was injured, destroyed evidence of the murder and obstructed the police investigation. The suit was settled privately for an undisclosed amount. In a statement issued through her attorney, Kathy Wahn said, although the defendants repeatedly chose to hide behind the Fifth Amendment, to me, their silence speaks volumes. Kathy told The Washington Post that she agonized over the decision to settle out of court to avoid
但约瑟夫·普赖斯曾在罗伯特的葬礼上担任抬棺人，这个位置是留给与他最亲近的人的。审判结束后，凯茜对约瑟夫、维克托和迪伦提起了非正常死亡民事诉讼。在诉讼中，她指控这三名男子在罗伯特受伤后未予施救、毁灭谋杀证据并妨碍警方调查。该诉讼在私下以未公开的金额达成和解。凯茜·沃恩通过她的律师发表声明称：“尽管被告一再选择躲在第五修正案背后，但在我看来，他们的沉默说明了一切。”凯茜告诉《华盛顿邮报》，为了避免
a lengthy civil trial. She thought about Robert and what he would want her to do. Quote, Nothing gave him more happiness than knowing I was at peace, focusing on love and optimism. This sentiment was echoed by Kathy's attorney. He believed that if the civil case had gone to trial, it would have been a spectacle to no purpose, as the respondents weren't going to come forward and provide any information. Quote, This case was never going to put anybody in jail or bring Robert back to life. The settlement funds were divided between the Wahn estate and a law clinic at the University of Pennsylvania Law School, which provides legal aid to inner city residents.
漫长的民事诉讼，她在庭外和解的决定上痛苦挣扎。她想到了罗伯特，以及他会希望她怎么做。引述：“没有什么比知道我内心平静、专注于爱与乐观更能带给他快乐的了。”凯茜的律师也呼应了这种观点。他认为，如果民事案件付诸审判，那将是一场毫无意义的闹剧，因为被告并不会主动站出来提供任何信息。引述：“这个案件永远不可能把任何人送进监狱，也不可能让罗伯特复活。”和解资金在沃恩遗产管理处与宾夕法尼亚大学法学院的一个法律诊所之间进行了分配，该诊所为内城居民提供法律援助。
The world lost a good man when Robert Wahn was killed. During his time at university, Robert ran the 13 Club, whose members went around campus performing random acts of kindness. It was fitting that at his graduation, Robert received an award presented to students who excelled in characteristics of heart, mind, and helpfulness to others. In the years after his murder, many organizations have dedicated scholarships and memorials in his honor. Joseph, Victor, and Dylan reunited in Florida as they had planned, where they bought a home and settled in as a family once more. As of mid-2021, nobody has been charged with the murder of Robert Wahn. Case file acknowledges Joseph Price, Victor Zaborski, and Dylan Ward's
罗伯特·沃恩遇害时，世界失去了一个好人。在大学期间，罗伯特负责运营“13俱乐部”，其成员在校园四处随机行善。恰如其分的是，在毕业时，罗伯特获得了颁发给在心灵、头脑和助人为乐方面表现优异的学生的奖项。在他遇害后的几年里，许多组织为纪念他设立了奖学金和纪念碑。约瑟夫、维克托和迪伦如计划的那样在佛罗里达州重聚，在那里他们买下了一栋房子，并作为一家人再次安顿下来。截至2021年中期，没有人因谋杀罗伯特·沃恩而被起诉。案卷承认约瑟夫·普赖斯、维克托·扎博斯基和迪伦·沃德享有
presumption of innocence. In the eyes of the law, all three men have not been found guilty of any of the crimes committed against or associated with Robert Wahn. The case continues to intrigue amateur and professional sleuths alike. Some believe that one of the residents of Swan Street Northwest had ordered another to kill Robert as the ultimate act of dominance. Others suggest that sexual assault was intended, but the murder itself was an accident. The general consensus is that one or all of the acquitted men at the center of the controversy know exactly who committed the slaying. A website dedicated to the case who murdered RobertWahn.com sums it up succinctly. Price, Zaborski, and Ward were not guilty, but they are not innocent.
无罪推定。在法律眼中，这三名男子均未被判定犯有针对罗伯特·沃恩或与罗伯特·沃恩相关的任何罪行。这起案件继续令业余和专业侦探们着迷。一些人认为，西北天鹅街的一位居民曾命令另一人杀死罗伯特，作为终极的支配行为。另一些人则认为本意是性侵犯，但谋杀本身是个意外。普遍的共识是，处于这场争议中心的被无罪释放的男子中，有一人或所有人确切知道是谁犯下了这起凶杀案。一个专门报道此案的网站“谁谋杀了罗伯特·沃恩网”（WhoMurderedRobertWahn.com）对此进行了精辟的总结：普赖斯、扎博斯基和沃德并非无罪，但他们也并非清白。
Due to the trio's continuing silence, Robert Wahn's murder is often described as a case that will never be solved. Kathy Wahn has a message for Joseph Price, Victor Zaborski, and Dylan Ward. Quote, I am moving on. I want to spend the next 40 years of my life focusing on good. They can rot from the inside out from all the secrets they chose to keep. That's their choice. I chose to move on. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
由于这三人的持续沉默，罗伯特·沃恩的谋杀案经常被描述为一桩永远无法破案的悬案。凯茜·沃恩给约瑟夫·普赖斯、维克托·扎博斯基和迪伦·沃德留下了这样一段话。引述：“我正在向前看。我想把我人生接下来的40年时间专注于美好的事物。他们可以从内到外因他们选择保守的所有秘密而腐烂。那是他们的选择。我选择向前看。”您好，本集目前尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。